now i don't know about you guys but i'm
getting hungry and i am so excited
because someone
very special to me is here in the
kitchen and she's an incredibly talented
chef
and we've been side by side now for
about three years and she's also my dear
friend
and i'm so excited to welcome her please
pillar valdez
[Applause]
someone i am always in the kitchen with
and
pilar and i bonded early on wanting to
make food because i am i'm a pendulum
like heavier lighter heavier lighter no
pretty little middle
and what to be lighter i had to do that
like chicken and broccoli thing and i
don't think that that's sustainable for
happiness and so what i really would go
off the rails is when i would do dishes
that weren't chicken and broccoli so
with pilar
we figured out how to make all these
craving
dishes but in a way that's really
healthy and great for digestion and
keeps the weight off i've been doing
this now
for a long time with you yeah and i'm
i'm
happy it's amazing you know what's
happening underneath here is horrifying
but
you know as long as it stuffs well into
clothes and that's as good as it's going
to get
well first off hi drew hi milan we're
here
i love you it's amazing thank you for
having me tell us about the dish we're
doing today all right so
i think this dish is perfect exactly
perfect for what you were talking about
okay so for today the weather is
starting to get colder we wanted
something cozy
something really comforting it's a
quinoa risotto
with winter squash seared mushrooms and
fresh herbs
delicious oh my god i just totally cared
[Music]
a kitchen cat the risotto is
traditionally made with rice right i'm
from the philippines rice is
queen i'm all about rice but sometimes
we have to make adjustments in our diet
and quinoa is the most amazing
substitute
in this dish because it's packed with
protein it's gluten free it's not a
grain it's actually a seed
and it has a tons of vitamins it's
really easy it's a great thing to have
in your pantry
so shall we jump in yes we shall okay so
the first thing you're gonna do
is actually roast your squash for this
recipe
i like stuff the thin skinned squash
hard to say
um delicata honey nut and the reason why
i recommend those squashes is because
when you roast them you don't have to
peel them afterwards you can use them
and eat them skin and all and you're
going to roast them at like 400 for
about 20
20 to 30 what i like to do is actually
cut the squash
into chunks like this okay i'm just
going to say and cook with a fork
this speeds up the cooking time so
you're going to cut it up drizzle some
olive oil
salt and pepper stick it in the oven 20
to 30 let it go
and then you're going to take it out and
we're actually going to make a puree
so you're going to take the chunks and
let's pop that in the blender
lovely and then you're going to have
some stock actually oh
there you go a little bit of vegetable
stock and we're going to add that in and
the thing is because this dish is
vegan we're not using dairy
dairy or cream in it basically
the puree acts
the pure i'm very non-mechanical so
you've got it over there
there's a button here and it says really
really
oh there we go we got it released
success
um wait now i'm doing it oh my gosh okay
here we go yeah baby lovely
eurason i love a blender it's so good
i know i love like i love a hand
blender it's so yeah they're really
useful tools
so basically the puree is going to act
as
that creaminess and richness in a dish
right in the risotto you think of
risotto it's like
has great movement it has all these
creaminess this one has
no um dairy in it i know i'm also okay
this is this one
luckily there's no release button we
twist twist it twist it there you go oh
you're mad
take that okay so you're going to want
it a really smooth and creamy
consistency basically
so that's what the puree looks like this
is representing
so in the meanwhile we had some of our
quinoa going you're good you're good i
put it in fold it in fold it in
keep mixing so the quinoa basically what
i like to do is i start
toasting it first in a dry skillet it
adds this really nice
nuttiness to the dish i have to say i've
not
seen people do that yeah and it's really
lovely 45 seconds in a hot dry pan
dry dry that's the key don't put the oil
in it
no no oil no nothing and then you're
going to add some liquid into that we
use vegetable stock
and you're going to bring that to a boil
and then turn it down to simmer and
you're going to mix it and stir it
and cook it for about 18 minutes
basically and you don't want it crunchy
and you don't want it
you definitely do not want it crunchy
you want it cooked
you want it that's the term in the
culinary world
absolutely perfect um so you're gonna
bring that down to a simmer and then
when it's cooked fully through about 18
minutes it's gonna have a looser
consistency
so if you're thinking risotto you know
that sort of movement
well then the thing about risotto is
it's made with rice and rice
usually i have to choose after i enjoy
it do i want it on the inner thigh or
the outer thigh
well you don't have to you don't have to
choose that with this no because it's
it's gluten free it's vegan
it's great so we're going to take our
puree
you're going to take gray which i've
represented
basically exactly it does look like
creamy cheese i mean i
love a risotto but i just can't my body
i always say my metabolism is a sloth on
valium asleep at the switch
so i need to be able to digest and when
you combine
rice and a protein your digestive tract
is fighting
digestion but with quinoa it literally
instead of sticking all over you
will move through your body in this
really immaculate way
um and then you get this beautiful
autumnal dish like this
so the other reason drew why i love this
puree too
is that it gives that creaminess you
know that that comfort that you're
looking for
in the risotto um it feels like it feels
like a hug in a bowl is what i like to
say which is i
love a hug and a bowl pillar
i want a hug and a ball so if you're
feeling a little fancy when you're
plating
you can do little dollops of the puree
if you still have some if you don't
no worries am i gonna start arranging
yes please arrange
a range away and with our trumpet
mushrooms they are trumpet mushrooms i
love mushrooms they're one of my most
favorite things
and the reason why i really like trumpet
mushrooms too is that
they have this very meaty texture so if
you're not eating meat it's a really
good substitute they're also really
beautiful
well i would love like some sliced steak
um
with my risotto and then this for me
really gave me that feeling the trumpet
mushrooms feel like
steak and like bacon and steak together
i see why vegans like gravitate towards
the mushrooms you can put some
delicious you know me i love a good
lemon zest especially in the winter or
the colder months when you need to perk
things up
fresh herbs go a really really long way
look at how gorgeous this is all right
you ready to do a beauty shot pilar
absolutely i'll tell you another thing i
love about this dish
is that most risottos do not keep well
no i mean quinoa yeah this keeps really
well
i really need it the next day and it's
delightful and you can also use these
ingredients to fold into a frittata
absolutely it's it's i feel like it's a
dish that keeps on giving
you can reheat it in a pan like with
just a basic slick of water bring to a
boil
toss it all in a pan and it just
re-steams and revives i call that
reconstitution there you go
well thank you so much pilar i love you
i love the life i get to live
because of you i've learned so much with
you
and from you and i'm excited to bring
what should be a really heavy
heavy dish to this lightness
that is so healthy and good for your
body but still gives all of that
satisfaction
so thank you delicious for the
satisfaction baby
all right